These are the classes that I came up with. There's a manager and photographers,
assignments and a portfolio or maybe multiple portfolios. The manager is
responsible for labelling or prioritizing and photographers are completing
assignments. So I think the manager has a method something like prioritizing
the assign that takes in a new assignment and figures out what to do with it,
and photographers have probably a method complete assignment. Thinking about
the methods that an assignment has, might be a little harder. Mostly, an
assignment should have a priority and a description. So it will probably be
possible to set the priority of an assignment. We'll also probably need to be
able to get the priorities, or compare them, so that the manager can figure out
which ones are the highest priority assignments. Maybe when an assignment is
finished, something happens with it. The portfolio probably needs to be able to
collect the finished assignments, and there should be a way to look at the
finish assignments as well. There are they things that you could have written
here, it's possible that customer would also be a good class or may be
priority. This would depend on how complicated you wanted to make your
priorities